(gentle music)
- So my lab is interested
in the development of
new high speed volumetric
imaging techniques
with the goal of understanding
how neural circuits
give rise to behavior.
You have heard already a number
of fascinating talks today
and also the motivations
for why we need these tools.
For us, I just want to
briefly summarize also
why, from a biological point of view,
we are developing these techniques.
This basically comes down to what has been
already mentioned previously
which is related to
the incredible density
of the interconnectedness
of the neurons in the brain.
So if we think about the human brain,
it has about 80 billion
neurons and we take out
two of the neurons randomly,
they are only connected
over two or three synapses.
So this alone shows us that in many cases
information may be not represented by
the individual elements of these systems
but rather by space of the network.
Therefore we intrinsically
need to move forward
and record from many
neurons at the same time.
So these are some of the questions
that we are interested in approaching
by developing these
technologies in the lab.
You have heard also about parallel efforts
that are going on on
the level of connectomes
that are related to the understanding
the wiring diagram or the connectivity.
But I think connectome will not be
answering us these questions.
It may be, so the
connectome may be putting us
a constrain on how we can
approach this question
but it will be not
sufficient to answer them,
and the best example comes from C. Elegans
that we also heard about.
The C. Elegans have only 300 neurons.
The connectome is mapped out
already for over 30 years.
Nevertheless, we still cannot predict
the behavior of C. Elegans.
So that is really the motivation for us,
why we want to move forward and develop,
move towards functional
maps of neural circuits
and particular what is
necessary is we need
to have tools that allow
us to do two things.
On one hand, we want to
be able to do stimulation
of defined spatial temporal
patterns effectivity
on a genetically identical set of neurons
and combined it with a
parallel and unbiased recording
from an entire population
while we are doing that.
And you can also think about
if you had these tools,
how we would be going conceptually
about approaching some of these questions
and what we would like
to do is we would like
to use methods from machine
learning, graph theory,
and information theory to approach them,
so in this example you can imagine that
the first set of tools could allow us to
position ourself in each
of these individual states
of this abstract space
that are state space
and then by having the ability
to observe how these points
evolve to other points,
we could build over time
transition probability
maps that could inform us
about the probability of the transitions
and use them to inform models
that could be generative of
the dynamics of the brain.
And ultimately what we are interested in
to work towards the discovery
of the underlying algorithms.
So about seven, eight years ago
when we started with this project
we first focused on the first topic
and developed basically
based on optigenetics
methods that allow us to sculpt
the distribution of light
and thereby stimulating individual neurons
at high speed and resolution.
And more over the last few years,
we have focused on the second topic
which is the parallel
and unbiased recording
and here we have developed a portfolio
of different techniques that
are addressing this question
from the level of small
organisms and C. Elegans
and more recently in the more
scattering brain of rodents
and we are moving also
towards the primate imaging.
So and today I would like basically
to give you a vignette
of some of the techniques
that we have developed,
mainly around the idea
of light sculpting that
has found application
both in the smaller,
semi-transparent C. Elegans
but as I will show you also
could be useful technique
for imaging the rodent brain.
So I would like to introduce
the basic idea of light sculpting
and those of you who
are familiar with optics
and microscopy techniques quickly realize
that in any kind of microscope basically,
the two parameters that are describing
the confinement of the light in our sample
are given by two things.
One is the spot size of the beam
that we choose to
illuminate the sample with
and the other one is the depth of field
or the axle confinement.
And you have heard this also in many talks
and with the problems that we are facing
in some sense is the fact
that these two parameters
that are fundamentally defining
the properties of light
in the sample are both given
by the wavelength of light, lamda,
and the numerical aperture of the optics
which is basically the ratio between
the diameter of the lens
and the focal length.
So it's as such the two
are inherently coupled
and so whenever we choose our spot size
to be a certain size, we inevitably end up
with a certain axle
confinement or depth of field.
And what we are basically asking
is how can we go beyond that and come up
with a technique that
can allow us to create
more arbitrary distributions
of light within the sample.
Now as you have heard,
the lamda is the basic
the wavelength of light, so if we set also
our wavelength fix then there is no way
around this coupling, so we will end up
inevitably for every given spot size
with given depth of field.
However if we go to a different situation,
you have heard also about
two photon microscopy
and in two photon microscopy
it's typically based
on the use of femtosecond pulses of light,
and use the so-called
uncertainty ration shape
which says that if you
choose the time very short,
you end up with an uncertainty and energy
which translates in an
uncertainty into colors
means that if we use femtosecond pulses,
we are no longer dealing
with a single wavelength
but with a spectrum.
As you can see at least by
exploiting that spectrum effectively,
this constraint that I was
mentioning before could be relaxed.
And so one way how this can be done
has been shown to be through the technique
of so-called temporal focusing
that I'd like to introduce to you briefly.
So the basic idea is we use
these femtosecond pulses of light.
We send them to disperse development,
for instance a gradient.
And what the gradient does
it sends the different
spectral component within the pulse,
along different spatial directions.
So as the pulse is propagating
away from the gradient,
the peak intensity drops off
as a function of propagation
and this leads basically to a dilution
of the photons in space,
so a pulse like that
is not very effective in
exciting the molecules,
so we reduce the two photon
excitation probability
as a function of propagation.
Now we reverse the process
by using a telescope
that is consisting of a lens
and our microscope objective,
and what that telescope
does is forms an image here
in the sample of our originally
short pulse on the gradient.
So what it means is that there will be
only one plane in the axle location
where all these spectral components
will be again co-localized
both in time and space,
leading to this high energetic pulse
that is very effective in
exciting the molecules,
but outside of that
region we are basically
dealing with a dispersed pulse
and such pulses are not very effective
in exciting the molecules.
So what we can achieve in this way,
we can achieve the localization
of excitation in the axle direction
by manipulating the spectral
properties of the pulse
and thereby basically decouple it
from the lateral confinement and have the,
reserve the lateral
confinement to basically
choose the spot size that we are
interested in in the sample
by basically illuminating the pulse
and decorating with a different size.
Just to draw the
comparison to the standard
two photon microscope that
we are more familiar with,
in the standard two photon microscope,
both the localization
laterally and axially are,
are generated by the focusing in space
and in the temporal focusing,
the axle localization is
generated by manipulating
the spectral properties of the pulse
and laterally we can focus in space.
So going to the problem of
large scale volumetric imaging,
we thought instead of now
exciting each of the neurons
at once and scanning it,
we could use that to
create a sheet of light
similar to Philipp's
light sheet microscopy,
in this case we can create a sheet
that is spanning about over 75 microns,
but still be axially confined
to about two microns.
So the main difference is that it is
a two photon excitation and it
doesn't require the geometry
that you saw before where
you have the two objectives
being orthogonal to each other.
So the idea was exciting a
field of view of that size
and then scanning that
sheet axially quickly
to capture the volume, and
we wanted to use GCaMP again
as our calcium indicator.
And the reason why we chose that size
was that we were interested in looking
at the brain of C. Elegans that is roughly
would fit in that volume.
So now if you want to
do two photon excitation
of a sheet of that size, this doesn't work
with the conventional laser sources
that people have been using
for two photon scanning microscopy.
You need significantly
higher pulse energies.
And for that, we used so-called
regenerative amplifier
that is shown here.
Basically it is seated by a conventional
two photon laser, and
what it does it creates
a significantly higher pulse energies
but at the lower repetition rates.
And so the pulses are
now send to the gradient
and here you have the
temporally focusing set up
that I was describing and the fluorescence
is now excited here and then collected,
separated by a dichloric and sent
to a detector that we have designed
based on so-called image
intensifier and a camera.
So overall you can see
that we can create now
a sheet that is about 75 microns
and being axially confined to two.
And what this allows us basically
is to go at very high speeds,
about 200 frames per second
or video rate of volumetric imaging.
So I said earlier we wanted to apply it
to the brain of C. Elegans and in neurons
we wanted to record from here
are located in so-called head
gamene and are shown here.
And this was done in a collaboration
with my former colleague, Manuel Zimmer
who is at INP.
So when we first expressed
GCaMP into all of these
head ganglion neurons, we saw that
due to the incredible
density of the neurons
and the small size, we couldn't
distinguish them individually.
So we came up with the idea of using
a nuclear localized version of GCaMP.
Basically it has a nuclear
localization sequence
that drove the expression
of GCaMP into the nuclei
and then we could nicely see that
the neurons were localized
in all dimensions.
So we could apply our wide
field imaging technique
and what I'm showing you here
is now a three dimensional
maximum intensity projection
of about 120 neurons
of the worm, and during
spontaneous activity.
So you see significant
Certain neurons are correlated,
others are anti-correlated
to each other, and this is all recorded
at about five volumes per second.
Our method can go about
four or five times faster,
but neurons in C. Elegans
have intrinsically
low responding or slow
responding time scales,
so we chose to image them
at the lower frame rates.
Now if you have such a
high dimensional system,
and you want to make sense out of it
so one simple way of asking
what are these neurons telling us
and what are they doing is to
do dimensionality reduction.
And one simple way of doing it is to
doing principle component analysis,
which is like asking what
are the most components
in this system that it
can rise to the variance
that we are observing here?
So when we do PCA,
we observe that about 70%
of the variance of this data
was explainable by the first
three principle components
that are now shown here, and here you see
the color is not encoding for the time.
Now again, the great
advantage of C. Elegans
comes from the fact that
we have the connectome,
so we can map these principle components
back to the known
connectome and what we found
was that the first principle components
was basically an antagonism
between different
interneurons and head motor neurons.
The second principle component
was a class of head motor neurons
and the third principle component
was antagonism between
different head motor neurons.
And we could now display
these principle components
in the face space and what we observed
was an interesting behavior which showed
sort of trajectory that was reproducible
and also was characterized by regions
that resembled attractors,
which you can see now in
this movie much better
as the states of the brain are evolving,
you see that the brain
seems to be spending time
in one of these attractors
and then it's switching back and going
to another attractor coming back again
and going on and on and so on.
So this was an interesting observation
and now we have increasing evidence,
mainly from the lab of Manuel
who has been looking also in these animals
during free behavior, and what we know is
these attractors correspond
now to unique motor programs
such as forwards crawling,
backward crawling,
left and right movement and so on.
So it seems that during
spontaneous activity,
the brain is randomly switching
between these possible motor programs,
and in the presence of the stimulus
this landscape could be tilted such
that the probability of one of them
being assumed over the
other could be modulated.
So we are following up
on this biologically
and interested in developing techniques
that allow us to observe this behavior
during free navigation as the animal
is making left right type of decisions
and see what kind of
things can we observe here?
So while working on
this, we have been also
trying to push these methods further
and I would like to give you an overview
of another technique,
and this is related to
how can we extend these
techniques into the mouse brain
and look at the larger
scale in scattering tissue.
So since many of you are
familiar with conventional
two photon scanning microscopy,
I just want to briefly take a moment
and outline the limitations,
the fundamental limitations
of two photon microscopy.
Let's assume that we were interested
in recording from a volume
that is about 500 micron cubed
and this would be about the size
of our diffraction limited spot
and we want to record from this
volume at about five hertz.
Now if we do the simple math,
this is our 500 million voxels
and recording them at five hertz requires
a 2.5 gigahertz acquisition rate
and therefore if you want to at least
excite each pixel with one pulse
we would need to have a laser
that runs at that repetition rate.
So lasers are conventionally
not available at this rate,
but even if they would be we
are facing another problem
that is that each individual voxel
we will be spending only .4 nanoseconds
which is about an order
of magnitude shorter
than the fluorescent's lifetime.
It means we will not be able to collect
any fluorescence out of these voxels.
So one conceptual
solution that we need to,
that we could employ here
is to minimize the spatial resolution
or the sampling grate
to the limit of the structure of interest.
So if we are interested for instance
in recording from individual cell bodies
or for individual neurons,
this resolution in some
way may be too good
and we are paying the price for that
by having a reduced
volumetric acquisition rate.
So the question becomes in some way
how can we relax the spatial resolution
in a meaningful manner?
So cortical neurons are a new order
of about 10 to 15 microns
and this is the size of
the point split function,
and in some ways people
are mainly using that
at least for this kind of imaging
because they are mainly interested
in the axle sectioning capability.
So we could in principle relax
the spatial resolution
laterally by for instance
underfilling the microscope objective,
but if we do that then we will end up
with a beam that is going
axially about 70 microns
for the reasons I mentioned before,
so what we really want
is to be able to sculpt
and isotropically sculpted
point split function
naturally and axially,
and so and thereby we would also need
to be able to decouple again the lateral
from the axial confinement,
and this is again
where light sculpting comes in.
So the idea here is now
instead of sculpting
our point split function
to be a large sheet,
as I was showing you before, in this case
we sculpt it to be an isotropically shaped
five micron sphere which shown here
and then we can scan
this by various methods.
This is in conventional
way, laterally and axially
to cover the volume.
So going back to the
example that I showed you,
so the one million pixels
are now translating
at five hertz to about five
megahertz acquisition rate
which is more realistically possible
with laser technology, and
also we get a much higher pixel
time at each of them so we can collect
significantly more fluorescence.
So nevertheless, if you look at the size
of this point split function
it's still 130 times larger
than the conventional
diffraction limited point split function,
so lasers that were
developed for that excitation
wouldn't work here because
they lack again the sufficient
laser pulse energies.
So we built a laser in our own lab
that was running at about 4.1 megahertz
and delivered .5 microjule
pulses that are enough
to excited these sized
point split functions
and this was integrated
into a scanned version
of the temporal focusing setup
which is consisting basically of mirrors
that are then scanning the beam
that is illuminating the grating
and the grating together with the lens
and the objective is performing
the temporal focusing
and we are scanning it up
and down with an objective.
So we collect now in fluorescence
instead of on camera from each of these
point split functions on a PMT
and the acquisition is also synchronized
with the excitation, so we are running
in the domain that we're having
one pulse per pixel only.
So this is just an impression
of the home built laser
and its integration to the
scanned temporal focusing microscope.
Next we were interested
in recording the activity
from en vivo in the mouse brain,
so we used mice where we expressed GCaMP
in the motor cortical areas and the PBC
while they were awake and were running.
So with this we can now go deep
and look at the layer two three neurons
and record from them as you can see here
at about 200 microns depth
from about 110 neurons or so.
We can go also deeper
to lay out five neurons
at about 470 microns,
record from a similar number of neurons
and what is important here now to realize
is we are now looking at a field of view
that is about 500 by 500 and
can capture that at 160 hertz.
So this is way too fast for a single plane
given the slow response time of calcium,
so what we could do is
to use the time instead
and look at two planes for
instance at the same time,
which is now shown here.
One at 150, the other one at 350 microns
recorded simultaneously,
or going back to the example
that I was outlining,
we can now go here and
record from a volume
that is now about 500 micron cubed,
encompassing about 4,000 neurons
and record all of that at about
three hertz volumetric rate.
So here you start also to see this
layered structure of the cortex,
the layered two three neurons
and the layer four neurons
that try to, that seem to coming out here
and one of the things that we are now
collaborating with with other labs
is trying to understand basically
how the cortex performs computation.
So we know that computation arises
from complicated interactions
between different layers
of the cortical neurons,
but how that is exactly
done is not very clear.
So just to show you what
we can also observe if you
do some simple data analysis.
This is basically looking at
the top .1% cross correlation
within a given time window,
what do we observe?
Interesting functional
connectivities or networks
that are forming
transiently then also then
changing over time.
Here the strength of
these lines are indicating
the degree of the correlation.
So one could look at
these things in principle
and ask how do they change
under different behavioral states
on the diseased states and so on.
So just want to briefly summarize,
so we saw that this idea of
light sculpting is possible
by decoupling the lateral
from the axial parameters of the beam
and this allows us in the
wide field configuration
is useful for quoting at high speed
in semi-transparent
organisms like C. Elegans
and in combination with
scanning it can be a method
that allows us to record on
the single cell resolution
from a large number of neurons
in the scattering brain.
Finally I just want to thank the people
in the lab who have been
involved in doing the work
and our collaborators
as well as our funding sources, thank you.
(applause)
(pleasant music)